sorry welcome to this video playing so
John yeah I think he didn't really have
a name they are right probably has you
want is your gr DS it's a very decent
player play them in on earlier accounts
really a lot check so probably going to
get the know with the main line I wanted
to save it okeee dizzam an uncommon move
it's not really what he's doing is very
uncommon set up put it put putting it
mildly mmm so let's see can I go a 4
here I think I can g 5 9 h 5 is winning
oops what not winning why not why not
okay you can go to the seven okay
somehow try to hold this position but it
looks damn ugly
I has to go 97 I think night h7 I'm
going to play you five okay why is that
working k night check here and then
Queen h5 something that's something
better now chat good enough Queen h5
this maybe you will be five so probably
just taking Jasmine Queen h5 now and now
and we need for queen of 7s winning and
G what about this here
going for 95 maybe just this move queen
of six is pretty substantial
25 maybe
look you one for a bishop g6 something
like that or look f3 rook g3 that's also
good it's also covering c3 it's not bad
not bad to have I wonder if f5 is a move
but i think i can take it actually takes
and then rook you one hope you 147 your
parents should work
queen of six rupees seven and rupee cell
now where's the Queen going ham nowhere
so I can start with the check IAM
channel let's go
cookie seven maybe first yep let's do
that first check so anything better
they're like I don't Jess so let's just
take the material I mean it's Queen
against two pieces so try for Queenie
seven
g-form my candle this also night g5g for
is a good way to to screw it up so let's
invade try to attack pawns so we're
doing g4 here after I think I want to I
want to prepare that King over to f4 and
then g4
Quincy 3 and 95 now I'm going to start
with this one oh no don't give me that
one ah jus wha what yeah I guess never
resigned ah by morning oh my god what a
joke of a game haha
mad I simply didn't see it i mean what
can you do simply didn't see it just
Queen c3 and when I cannot say he
resides I mean he could have resigned
like her after move 15 or something but
he didn't end it paid off yeah why rezai
since I just blundered this what can you
do could have done that one move early
actually I think I played it played it
ok up to that point you have to activate
the king that's all good and yeah kini
three this is also just oops sorry this
is also completely end up and go here
it's the Queen Queen against two pieces
the only way to screw it up or something
something idiotic like like like what I
did check check yeah probably yeah I
should've chatter just kept this on and
to take further yeah here check this is
actually winning another piece yeah
that's a bit of a shame because the game
was really good and from my partner so I
have to say sorry I'm probably getting
flak again for that but what your lady
was just really really really awful g5
allowing this allowing the pin is bad
and allowing f voice even worse your
black is almost busted what is the
engine giving just +1 hmm ok to the
engine wants to defend this position no
disposition we just downright ugly and
probably still it was this and how it
goes up to 1.5 now came and NTM and this
is just a winning position Quincy one
wins the sweater but occasion matter of
you have tons of tons of wins and you
have to go for for one of them check
check yeah I can be happy with that
check just
just this one one moment of idiocy yeah
this is the this is the best you're just
going back here and no I'm just picking
up the pawn because you cannot you
cannot keep it no I'm attacking like
this it's falling apart yeah I just I
just didn't see Bishop c4 okay well
thanks for watching